by the end i really i believe pleased
with the outcome but um i don't want to
do that again want some Marvel's Luke
Cage finally premiered on netflix and ET
caught up with the Stars and showrunners
to get their take on the episode that
everyone is talking about we got to talk
about episode 4 finally getting to see
the origin story has talked to me about
filming that whole process of it all
everyone can attest that felt like two
episodes I felt like that episode would
never end they took me to like a scuba
diving class to like get in acclimated
to the water pressure and his new
claustrophobic time he put the mask on
being underwater the pressure of the
water in your chest it was really
important that week that I do that
because on the day of filming it took a
lot longer than I thought it was it was
cold it was it was not ideal at all but
we got the shot and made it look really
cool and I bought into it um by the end
I really I really pleased with the
outcome but um I don't want ever do that
again comic book fans were even treated
to a little Luke Cage easter egg look
like a damn for many people that is the
look of what he is but eight for many
people you also very understand that
that was a look in the early 70s and wow
a lot of that is coming back and and is
part of it this is the show that takes
place present-day are you glad that you
don't have to run around like I mean I
was happy to give the fam boys what they
wanted but I really did want to keep the
look that we had established just for
sake of being credible and taken
seriously and it was visually important
so looking ahead in the Marvel verse
mike is excited to reprise his role as
Luke Cage in 2017 when he teams up with
daredevil jessica jones and newcomer
iron fist in the defenders nina he don't
just put a target on your back what i
would like to see in defenders if I had
my druthers um would be to see the
relationships which mean the characters
develop I mean they have to meet we have
to see that that format or formulation
of ideas and what are we doing here
we're not just gonna come in a room and
go hey let's be the defenders how does a
safe place and that's going to be the
interesting part and then after that
we'll see who's but we have to kick
you
you